all right well thanks guys hi I'm Tommy
I've been studying topic models since
about 2013 topic models and they're
newer cousins text embeddings are latent
variable models of language latent means
that you don't see what your model is
trying to estimate and that makes it
hard to know whether you have a good
model or a really really bad model that
just looks good or a really really bad
model that you don't know if it's good
or bad or not and I am among other
things a PhD student and my research
centers around ways to make topic models
better in that vein today I'm going to
talk to you about a little experiment I
ran so before we get to that let's take
a step back and just review things so
first of all a quick show of hands who
here has heard of latent dere clay
allocation and good number of people who
here's used it so that's probably at a
third of the room actually so that's
that's pretty good so Lda is basically
probabilistic matrix decomposition you
have three hyper parameters so k is the
number of topics you have to fix that
yourself alpha controls the
concentration of topics within a
document or what's in that theta matrix
there and then beta controls the the
concentration of words within a topic or
that Phi matrix and you know anyone
who's used LD a or talked to somebody
who's used it will probably find
somebody who is freaking out about what
do I pick for these things especially
that number of topics I have no idea
what a right or wrong answer is and a
little note on vocabulary since I know
it's in our conference there's lots of
statisticians here so in machine
learning land they use Hyper parameters
the definition is slightly different
than Bayesian statistics so in machine
learning land a hyper parameter is
anything that you have to set as a
modeler rather than a parameter that is
learned or fit while you're training
this algorithm so that's how we're
using that today and so the foil for my
Lda in this comparison of this
experiment is latent semantic analysis
or LSA or LSI quick show of hands who
here has heard or and/or used this
method before actually fewer people than
L da that's that's actually kind of
crazy so LSI has been around since about
1989 so it's not probabilistic it's just
a matrix partitioning algorithm so you
take a document term matrix or a tf-idf
matrix and you are going to factor it
using a single value decomposition it's
not what you get isn't probabilities but
in general you're still getting a
distribution of topics amongst a
document and a distribution of words
within topics it really only has one
hyper parameter and that's K the number
of topics
you could get fancier with this but for
now the the simplest version that's just
that one and like I said topic models
and embeddings they're their latent
variable hop models they're hard to
evaluate the overwhelmingly most popular
evaluation method is something called
semantic coherence so there's a bunch of
different like measures for this and
formulas but the idea here is that you
can look at a distribution of words from
a topic and as a human being you're like
oh that makes sense to me and so the one
that I use often ships with text miner
it's a package I wrote that tries to
look at the probability of words
co-occurring within a document
controlled for statistical independence
of those words don't worry about that
now
so coherence is a rule is a really
popular way to evaluate these models I'm
not going to talk about goodness of fit
I can bend your ear about it later in
the break and then task-specific
accuracy so a lot of times people are
not using topic models or embeddings
because they actually care about the
model itself and want to interpret it
instead what they're doing is trying to
make some sort of numeric features of
text and then feed that into some
downstream tasks like document
classification so maybe we can say a
topic model is good or not good if
depending on how well it does on this
downstream task so the two things to
keep in mind is we
go forward and I tell you that this
experiment is coherence that's sort of
like how interpretable is this accuracy
that's sort of like how well did this do
for whatever that downstream machine
learning task was so I've actually been
introduced as this is Tommy he still
uses LD a better than that he's he's
okay but a whole chapter of my
dissertation is just going to be this
gif on repeat last year especially has
seen an explosion of deep learning based
texts embeddings that have really
advanced the state of the art in natural
language processing but here is my
argument for why this still matters so
first of all people still use this model
like a lot so knowing how to do it
better is very helpful to a large number
of people even if we're not state of the
art second of all I think that studying
these comparatively mechanically simpler
topic models can actually give us some
insight into these much fancier more
complicated deep learning embedding
models that are arguably trying to do
largely the same thing and third we
stopped to the machine learning
community really stopped studying Lda
when machine largely deep learning for
image recognition came out and so we
never actually even really learned how
to fit a good Lda model before we
stopped caring and moved on so I'm
actually not convinced that a well
specified Lda model wouldn't be fairly
competitive with some of these newer
methods but you know watch this space in
the next couple of years and see if I
try and write that paper we'll see how
right or wrong I am there that's that's
what my guts telling me but if you
insist so in this work I use the neural
network to write our code to use a
Bayesian optimization service for topic
modeling so I've already really spoken
to this a bunch today but topic models
are hard to evaluate but think about
what people use them for you know that's
either I want to interpret something
from it or maybe it there's just this
downstream task that's a little bit more
objective than this fuzzy latent
variable thing and so maybe we can
optimize a topic model for these things
and see what the mechanics were that led
to doing well or poorly on that task
right so here's basically the goal take
a topic model use it to embed some
documents and some latent topic space
use that embedded text to train a
classifier so for this I use the twenty
newsgroups data set and if I can date
myself just a little bit for the the
younger folks in the audience a news
group is like a subreddit but but from
the 1990s and so that the task here is
to predict from which of these twenty
News groups or subreddits the document
came from and so the idea here is that
using my optimization service and I'm
going to talk about in a little bit I'm
gonna create a bunch of observations
around what hyper parameter settings
gave me what values on these evaluation
metrics so I can get a sense of what are
the underlying mechanics of these models
and how do they work there's an hour
conference so I don't have a ton of our
code that's just not my style but here's
my tech stack here I have a policy
against reading slides so instead let me
justify the selection of random forest
again neural networks are eating the
world random forest just works it's like
an 85 percent solution and since I
wanted to spend my time studying the
topic models I didn't want to like
pollute that with a more complicated
model that has its own hyper parameters
that need to be tuned and optimized I
wanted something I could just use out of
the box so I just straight up use the
defaults from the random forests package
so I talked around this a little bit so
I used a hyper parameter optimization
service called cig ops what this is is
it's an ensemble of Bayesian optimizers
so every time you report an observation
of with these hyper parameter settings I
got this evaluation metric score it says
well then try these new ones and you're
basically creating a dataset on how well
your model searches through this space
ideally you're you're fitting fewer
model
than like using a random search or grid
search so you can get to something
optimal quicker but you can also still
create this data set of how well my
model performed and study it so
basically you take your training data
you train a model you report this to the
service it then suggests new hyper
parameter settings you wash rinse and
repeat do that in a loop and then
finally you get what might be an optimal
model according to that metric you're
trying to maximize full disclosure my
company has invested in sig out so I'm
not just a client
I'm also an investor but I've used it
here I've used it for my deep learning
class which is the last class of my PhD
which I did last year so investment
status aside I think it's a pretty nifty
tool it's pretty pretty useful it's
helped me so at a high level this is the
process take your documents clean them
then you're gonna train a topic model
then you're gonna train a classifier and
stick the sig up optimization loop in
the middle here
pretty standard cleaning and curation
process I used you know grams I removed
both stop words and words that appeared
in fewer than five documents nothing
crazy there but because of a the
scalability issues of Lda or at least
the Gibbs sampler that I wrote and using
sig out I ended up with some pretty
wonky training and test splits so I took
my split the data set into thirds at
first so you know you have your training
set then you have your validation set
and then finally you have this test set
and instead I took my training set and
then split off the first thousand
observations use that to train the topic
model then got topic predictions for the
remaining 5,600 observations use that to
train random forests and then for that
middle validation set there I then got
topic predictions and then random
forests class predictions and then
reported those metrics off to sig off so
that was all out-of-sample I haven't
gotten to that bottom set here this is
an ongoing work for a blog post I'm
writing but what I'll do for that last
one is just take whatever optimal model
I choose and get a true out-of-sample
thing
so then here this is that whole
optimization loop so sig apt has an R
API it's called sig opt are it's pretty
standard if anyone's used cloud services
before you get an API token you're gonna
set it as a system environmental
variable
you're gonna declare an experiment and
hand that off to that API so that it
actually knows what the heck it's doing
you're going to declare a function to
train your model and calculate those
evaluation metrics and report them out
and then you're gonna loop over that
process that I described before and so
here's the only R code in this
presentation so up there at the top is
setting that environmental variable you
don't get to see my Sagat the API key
because I don't want that in the public
domain set this experiment here so I've
got K I've got alpha asked me in the
break why that says beta some naught
beta and then you'll regret asking me
that but I won't let you escape I will
make you learn and then I ran for
parallel workers and got a hundred
observations so I got a small dataset of
100 observations of this hyper parameter
space for these models this big old
function does that train test split that
I talked about trains the topic model
applies it to a held out set oops
trains random forests applies that to a
held out set calculates the metrics and
then spits those out at the the bottom
of the function and then here in step
four is that main optimization loop so
there's the system sleep up there what I
discovered is that when I was running it
in parallel my computer got ahead of sig
app server and then it would just hang
and I would never get any results so I
found that by putting the system to
sleep it would like sig app server could
sir could spin its workers up I've
reported that to the sig app guys like
hey maybe you should document that or
fix it they're engineers around the case
and then the bottoms where you get the
optimal experiments so that's all fine
in theory how did this work out for me
in practice so far so good let's use
Google instead of my wussy little
MacBook to run this
don't don't let your code run for a week
without checking on it
I can I can think of better ways to
spend 40 dollars
I should have seen this coming this
wasn't a huge data set I don't know what
I was thinking but you know eventually I
fixed it and got results in a few hours
and now I have this nice little issue
that I'm going to open up on github that
says you know go fix your Gibbs sampler
so as I said I optimized for both
accuracy and coherence and what this
plots here is how you get accuracy
versus coherence for a whole bunch of
hyper parameter settings for both LSA on
the left here in purple and Lda in green
on the right the orange lines are what's
called a Pareto frontier so basically
what that's saying is you can't at that
point you can't do better on one of
these metrics without doing worse on the
other so these would be considered like
optimal points and then you have to
decide do I care more about
interpretability or do I care more about
classification accuracy so a couple
things jump out to me right away
so one Lda is across the board way more
accurate at that classification task
than an LSA LSA only produces more
coherent topics for like terrible
accuracy scores so you can interpret it
but the model doesn't seem to be very
good at predicting the class accuracy at
least not on this data set the the
trade-off between coherence and accuracy
for Lda on that on that Pareto curve is
really tight so I don't have to give up
too much an interpret ability to get
some pretty good prediction accuracy and
then all those points inside of the
Pareto curve would be inefficient points
right and so another thing that jumps
out at me is that I think because Lda
has a much more complicated hyper
parameter settings that you can do you
get a lot more inefficient points which
goes back to my earlier thing of we got
distracted before we even knew how to
use these models you know there's a lot
of ways to specify not very useful Lda
models but done well you can get
something that's reasonably good at
least on this data set for this task so
sig opt they've got a fancy user
interface that I'm not going to bring up
now but they report hyper parameter
importance scores that's sort of like
variable importance from random forests
or something like that
and so what I can see for Lda at least
is that K is by far the most important
parameter so the number of topics is by
far the most important in terms of your
accuracy but then all three of those
parameters have to work in concert
together to get interpretable models to
get reasonably good coherence scores
again fitting to this these are this is
a complicated space you can fit a model
that isn't very good pretty easily the
sake of brevity I'm not going to show
you all the graphs I made but in terms
of number of topics here's comparing Lda
and LSA so again we see in terms of both
coherence and accuracy Lda is a lot
better but another thing I see is that
accuracy is pretty high and I get pretty
tight groupings across this whole range
of the number of topics for for Lda but
coherence is a whole lot noisier again
fitting to like owning to this like
getting all three of those parameters
right when you fit your model is what's
going to get you a good one or a bad one
all right and all right so what so I
guess if you can afford the compute I
would say use Lda not LSA I can't really
speak to how it performs against these
neural network based based methods but
you know someday I'll I'll test that out
Lda is pretty computationally intensive
but trying to fix my Gibbs sampler has
like led me to realize that there's been
some new algorithms in the last few
years where people have tried to fit Lda
in a much more scalable way so let's
watch this space maybe I'll implement
one in text miner maybe I'll get
distracted who'd notice I have a DD but
one thing to consider here is that I got
93% accuracy on this classification task
on this data set with with Lda pretty
much for free right like
out of the box no matter what my setting
of K was like it was just really high on
only a thousand documents and then I had
held out sets of about you know it was
about ten thousand or more of the the
documents there that had ended up
predicting on that's that's pretty good
for such a small sample to generalize
that well maybe a property the data may
be a property of the algorithm probably
an interaction between the two and so
like I said I used sig out in my deep
learning class I've used it for this
product yeah my company invested in it
but it's a pretty useful tool I'm also
still bullish on Lda even in 2019 come
find me in the break and I'll talk your
ear off and again make you regret ever
having asked me any of these questions
and since I've got about a minute left I
want to do a quick pitch so we're hiring
here at in-q-tel
you know I've been there about two and a
half years I'd reached a point in my
career as a data scientist where I
gotten up into management and I realized
that you know management but I was still
writing code for half my day but I
realized that none of my problems were
technical they were all human problems
so like convincing my clients that the
data that they had was insufficient for
the question they wanted to ask and
convincing them to go collect a sample
and then they would argue with me know
machine learning supposed to fix it and
I just was not equipped to like win that
argument without pissing people off and
so you just end up sort of being like I
guess I'll model through and build you a
model so I came to this investment firm
which is a very person driven business
to specifically work on those skills and
at first I got my butt kicked and had to
have my colleagues bail me out of my
first negotiation but bit by bit I got
better and better and better and more
recently I just had a project where I
was able to convince our customers like
no you need to focus on the data you
can't just like take this black box
machine learning model and get what you
want out of it so I feel you know taking
a couple years out of direct you know
doing tech has helped it helped me so
when I go back into the world I can get
the prod
that that are the right ones resource
because I can convince people to do it
so if you want to talk let me know in
the break and then that's the end of my
time so thank you very much guys
[Applause]